so make make your stuff like tight and
pretty realistic
okay
okay let's go f the trick is to ground
vent your
everything and then
uh you're kind of balancing his
weight I how to work a shot B like it's
so heavy out there you have to learn how
to balance its weight so it's not so
heavy okay so boom he's throwing a one
two right so home underneath okay once
we get kinding of stabilized CU if we're
not stabilized and it's going that way
then you're going to trap those leg and
take them
out he SS like he's like
bracing so you're here I'll lower myself
a change here I come underneath you can
use your chest too boom
Watch How I use my chest
[Music]
slower
boom okay change grip
underneath legs I'm going to use my
chest
boom and we'll turn if I slam you you
won't be able to turn
over you want to see no okay
boom boom you're going to stabilize see
I oh too much energy
one up chest
turn
on it's very
light very light stabilized
boom you can see how light he
is
go
okay so feel where you're sticking to me
okay so here
obviously right right
forearm right head you see got it
shoulder you see okay so all that
sticks I come underneath I'm going to
bring you onto me you see with all that
stickiness I press up and I'm going to
spin you on my
chest so that you end up head head okay
all right try
again is jab cross bone
okay so I'm going to do
this kick par okay don't throw it it's
there boom then too
long no you won't be a did you what
happened to you last I you fell you see
okay so boom take the two on
one two on one all right look
right here you see yes elbow on the
inside and you use the
arm he's coming in boom he whatever your
does close to the two arm one close
more use your
body and we'll take it down to follow
side move move
here all right let's
try
[Music]
all
right
so that that first technique where
you're uh moving around he's just up
here and you're moving around it's it's
exactly like this
technique so it's just C ho so I move
him
around exact same
technique and then the other technique
from the two on one when you're here
it's just
so you'd have you'd have Cole it's right
there it's right here in fact you could
you could just ditch
him but we're using it to take him
down okay you already we have the arm
cross body do you feel it so I can come
on and you're going to have the gift WRA
you have your wrist lock there okay you
can
find position
here
okay